good morning
last friday i spoke with president
zielinski
to assess the situation in ukraine that
is created by russia's aggressive
actions
we discussed how the european union
could continue to support ukraine both
in the immediate and the medium term
and as ever the european union stands by
ukraine
in these difficult circumstances we are
very firm in our resolve
the european union has already provided
significant assistance to ukraine both
in the support of the country's
resilience and the country's
modernization but also specifically to
fight the covet-19 pandemic
since 2014 the european union and the
european financial institutions have
allocated over 17 billion
euros in grants and loans to the country
so today
i am announcing a new financial
assistance package to the country
made both of emergency loans and grants
first of all the commission proposes a
new emergency macro financial assistance
package of 1.2 billion euros
this package will help ukraine now
to address its financing needs due to
the conflict
we count on the council of the european
parliament to adopt this emergency macro
financial assistance as soon as possible
we will then proceed
to the rapid disbursement of the first
tranche of 600 million euros
we will soon start work
on a second larger macro financial
assistance program
to support the country's modernization
efforts
secondly the commission will almost
double its bilateral assistance to
ukraine in grants this year
another 120 million euros will be
allocated
this support will strengthen ukraine's
state building and resilience efforts
and finally on top of this we will
continue to invest in the country's
future
thanks to our investment plan for the
country the plan aims at leveraging over
6 billion euros in investment
and let me be clear once more
ukraine is a free and sovereign country
it makes its own choices
and the european union stands by the
side of ukraine thank you